my daughter Rachel Cruz is with me as we
continue talking about how to raise
money smart kids are subject to day's
work hey work now teaching a kid to work
and we were talking about putting them
on commission paying them say a certain
amount for a certain Shore and one of
the things we do is put a commission
worksheet it's actually an item in
financial peace Junior which is a box of
teaching aides to teach your kids about
money but it's a little dry erase board
in that box and you can put it on your
refrigerator door and when they do the
chore you check off the chore and we had
it real simple when our kids were little
ed like five chores a week and they got
a dollar each so it's five dollars if
they did them all if they didn't do them
they got four dollars if they didn't do
them they get three dollars or whatever
it out one of the things that always
comes up when I do that and Rachel you
probably run into this in
question-and-answer when you've spoken
to is well I I believe kids ought to
just work because they're part of the
family I don't think they ought to get
paid what do you think about that I
think that there needs to be a balance I
think there are things in the house that
need to be done because you're part of
the family so for instance growing up in
the Ramsey household the kitchen was
kind of the perimeter of you do not get
paid you set the table because you're
part of the family you take your dishes
to the sink because you're part of the
family as you get older you wash your
dishes and put in the dishwasher because
you're part of the family you help Mom
clean the dishes as teenagers because
you're part of the family so all of
kitchen stuff we just did because again
we were part of the family so I think
there are good things you know to say
hey in life you're going to work some
and you may not get paid a dollar every
time you do it kind of thing so it's
good for them to know that that's an act
of love it's an act of service sure yes
exactly but I think that doing it the
extreme way of saying what we're not
going to pay them for anything I think
you miss a really great opportunity
again to associate work and money for
your little kids we're trying to create
teachable moments because they're going
to spend it differently save it
differently and give it differently if
they have the sense that they've earned
it and that's tied to work and so you
want some of both we kind of had three
types of things around the house we have
the every
anything that you did because you're
part of the family and didn't get paid
for you had the every day or every week
thing you did that was on commission and
you did get paid for the way the
occasional special project that
everybody just jumped in yeah you didn't
get paid back yeah you remember like
cleaning the yard
it's a putt cleaning the garage island
off the back porch and springing it yeah
all the furniture out and pressure wash
and kids are hauling the furniture out
of there and the bigger they got the
more the furniture they hauled and um
that's good I forgot about those yes you
know to this day your brother who's in
college there's no chance that his mom
sets her own suitcase in the call into
the car when we're going on a trip he
sets it in there no chance I'm set that
in there he sets it in there now I'll
help him load and stuff like that but
I'm you know he's big strappin guy he
can handle it and so that's an act of
love and act of service in the family
the other thing that kind of comes up in
that too that when you're talking about
kids working in kids getting paid
Rebecca
sends us a tweet and she says what are
your thoughts on paying kids for making
good grades I would say it's probably a
motivation for some it would have been a
motivator for me but you and Mom would
not pay grade so we didn't get favored
grades that was something you're
expected to do you're expected to get
good grades new guys were never overly
strict on grades we were not kind of a
straight-a family if you didn't make an
A you got in trouble you guys weren't
that strict but you needed to be
responsible for your schoolwork and you
didn't get paid for that and some
parents do that I mean I don't think
there's a right or wrong honestly with
that subject that doesn't bother me I
think it can be a motivator for some
kids but again that could be a lesson
say hey you have to learn in life you
have to be a lifetime learner you're not
going to get paid every time you read a
book so I think maybe instilling that
early could be a be better than paying
but I think if you pay for grades I
personally don't know your thoughts we
have talked about this personally it
doesn't bother me doesn't bother me a
bit we didn't have day we didn't we
didn't we didn't do it and the reason we
didn't do it was we felt like it was
like brushing your teeth or taking a
bath that you need to do your homework
and you need to do good grades that's
what you do and it's a gift you're
giving yourself by the way not someone
else and you're not you're not serving
the household in any way by doing that
other than you're going to be smart
enough to be able to leave later
but other than that you know you're not
this is something you're doing for
yourself whether you realize it or not
when you're a kid but I think sometimes
I had we had lots of kids when I was
growing up their parents are paying $1
for a you know a B and $2 for an A or
whatever it was those kinds of things so
I don't think it's evil either way we
just didn't do it Sharon and I didn't do
it we made it more of a part of the
rhythm of our life for you guys to get
your studies done and for us to look
over your shoulder and make sure and
occasionally to actually help you do
some of those studies but you're right
we were not we're not academic freaks in
the sense of hardcore academic people we
read we learn were smart all of us but
we don't you know the difference in a
3.8 and a 3.9 did not bother us
substantially you know we weren't
freaking out over that because we did
figure out a long time ago that GPA is
if you know your stuff well enough to
function then GPA is not really an
indicator of future success so in the
3.8 by the way was Daniel that would be
that big time y'all right that's my
ramsey child he's got a graduate we call
it the ropes around his neck yeah he's
really pretty interesting so that's
pretty good so uh so let's talk about
now moving on up to elementary and
junior high kids some of the things that
you're seeing with that and some of the
recommendations you've got for that I
had a caller while I go say 13-year old
do we put them on a checkbook I think
probably up to the age of I would say
thirteen or fourteen ish you keep them
on the commission worksheets system
where you pay once a week and then I say
once you got bumped up I think I was 14
or 15 when I got my own checking account
and what mom and dad did which I think
was so smart was take the amount of
money that they would normally spend on
us as kids and deposit that amount of
money each month into a checking account
our own checking account so we had a
debit card in a checkbook and anytime
there was a cheerleading fee or
back-to-school shopping or going out on
the weekends with friends all that money
came out of that checking account and
when the money was gone it was gone and
we didn't get any more money until the
first of the next month unless we had a
part-time job
we made our own money right so that
that's um worked well um so yeah I mean
another q13 may be a little too young
but I think there's different 13
year-olds and different levels but as I
hit those teenagers they enter a
different phase of the work they can now
work outside the home you can do
babysitting for someone else keep the
neighbor's dog a little bit older they
can start to take the quote mall job so
the work subject takes on a little
different feel at that point yeah and I
encourage parents I think it's great for
them to go get a job outside the home I
think that's something that every child
needs to experience I only did it for a
season and I worked at the mall during
Christmas which was crazy and I I hated
it and honestly I quit and started my
own job I started my own little business
because I'm function more in that way
but it was good for me to go and work
under you know a boss work with other
people file a tax form you know I mean
you learned so much when you go and work
somewhere so I think getting that is
important for teenagers but I think also
on their own if they want to go do their
own thing like a babysitting or a lawn
care service or kind of have their own
thing running I think that's just as
great teaching them to run their own
business and those kinds of things one
of the things I wanted to warn parents
of on that is when kids start to be
teenagers and they start to quote earn
their own money unquote outside the
household or even inside the household I
want you to not surrender your role as
parent you're still in charge just
because little Johnny has a job cutting
grass doesn't mean little Johnny gets to
buy anything he wants to buy you're
still in charge so you're going to where
you're going to you know my with my
girls for instance they were going to
wear clothing that's appropriate and
modest regardless of whether they earned
the money to buy it or not and you know
and piercings that are appropriate and
so on that are that aligned with our
value systems I don't surrender my right
to control your purchases because you
have a job mr. beautiful and highly
intelligent and knows everything 16 year
old give me a break I'm still your dad
and I'm still in control of your life
and I can still take you out make
another one
just like you so um you know that kind
of stuff don't don't surrender that
because you know parents well how can I
tell him what to do with his money it's
his money no it's your money he's a
miner he doesn't have any rights in any
rights he doesn't get to choose that so
and you don't need to surrender that so
Rachel thanks for hanging out with me
thanks for having me back on fun Rachel
Cruise we're talking about smart kids
how to raise money smart kids so they
don't live in your basement till they're
32 that's the plan eject we don't want
to have failure to launch
we're going to work on that around here
Rachel's going to come on and help us
periodically with that especially in
this season when we get ready to launch
this book this is the Dave Ramsey show
you
you